look at this dark a Blair ass thing hey
lawyer this they look at that
looks like Selene straight out of it I'm
watching you I'm watching you I'm
watching you I'm watching you welcome
back to another episode of SCP
containment breach for some reason unity
wouldn't work so I'm going to go back
into this and we're gonna do ah we're
gonna immediately run away from Larry
I'm gonna immediately go okay I'm just
gonna gun it through the gas because I
know there's gas and I'm just a run
that's all there is to it or as I'm
gonna go
so we just got to go yeah we got to hit
the button we got to hit the button we
got to hit the button we got to hit the
button to get through it and then we're
gonna get through it and then we lead
him through the Tesla gate and we go go
I got I hit it ah my eyes my eyes okay I
should probably keep going because I
doubt that he's gonna be he's probably
gonna be right by me oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god I need I need the mask so I can
run infinitely go okay he's right by me
he's definitely right by me okay okay
he's definitely okay trigger okay let's
see if this gets him
ooh okay here we go here we go come on
come on come on you you Oh get [ __ ] Oh
get straight up do it
Oh get all that dick oh you got direct
well you got direct oh yeah it do okay
well are you right outside the door
better not be right outside the door
okay I'm gonna take the gas mask off so
I can actually see [ __ ] okay so there's
way through the middle through there I
don't remember what was over here what
was in the way here anything important
or nothing important at all oh that's
where that goes okay so let's not go
back just yet let's go around the other
loop just to make sure that we cover all
of our bases and make sure that they do
in fact belong to us and then we can
continue
Chewbacca is that you again I don't know
what that is you only check this again
also I don't know why I have the badge I
probably don't need it
oh oh okay I don't remember these but
okay I probably have a high enough fetch
yeah okay you buying me okay so this is
scp-713
I I can use this ring it's my advantage
if I'm smart about this to put this in
here I don't have the burnt note but I
remember seven four one four was the
code on the note I just don't know if
that changes from time to time I think I
remember yeah okay so the thing about
this is is it it causes you to go slow
be sluggish reduce mental capacity but
it is a shield it is a shield versus
like some kind of chemical or poison or
like mimetic effect which is something
that the SCP foundation really loves
they love their memes they do love their
memes indeed they do cuz I'm gonna drop
the leaflet a [ __ ] I put this in here
i'ma take it I'm not gonna put it on but
just in case I might need something for
that I'm gonna keep that
wait wait wha wait wait what is this
wait I don't know what this is
wait okay ham I think I can drop a
battery I don't need the origami anyway
wait no that's the locket Oh Oh then oh
[ __ ] okay all right resistance to
disease and toxins increased by 500
percent compared to accepted ld50 or
death rate after a total of 10 minutes
of exposure and 100 1000 percent
affected after 15 minutes muscular
systems begin bla increasing strength
and pain tolerance by 200 to 300 other
systems continue to optimize Class D
personnel exposed to the device for over
an hour
total begin mutating into shapeless mass
of tissue the conversion time accelerate
with continued exposure to scp-427 hmm
right okay weird so it cures the common
cold in about two to four minutes but if
you the longer you have it the more it
morphs you into something horrible so
someone took it it's not here so someone
must have been really desperate if they
needed that and then I'm pretty sure
they turned into something real bad okay
so that's good to know I guess anybody
here
anybody no okay all right what is over
here man I remember that yeah like in
these places there used to be just
plague place or land pull their empty
stuff okay that one's bad I know this is
the book of diseases I don't want to
read that because every single one I
read I will get so that's bad don't pick
that this is I don't know what this is
what is this
oh the key Oh I'll leave you an origami
I'll stick the key we do need the key
okay so the key is to a door that leads
to that dimension where that animation
was made from where the sweet sweet
little thing didn't want to kill me so
that's what to the mystery door so we
got the key we got a lot of [ __ ] got a
lot of [ __ ] I don't need this anymore
I'm gonna drop that wait what was it
didn't then something disappeared in
front of my script wait wait wait did
you guys see that
wait no tell me I'm not crazy wasn't
there some text right in the middle of
the screen I swear I saw something okay
all right I'm trusting you that I'm not
I'm just crazy on that one okay all
right anyway keep going oh it's the
hallway of repeating am I wrong
it's the repeating hallway yeah it is
ooh a cup I think I need the cup for
something no not the card need the cup
the cup for the UM the thing okay so
this is just the repeating hallway as
you repeat in it it gets weirder and
weirder write the recursive spatial
phenomenon yeah okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm actually gonna go save because
I'm pretty sure that the deeper you go
into it eventually it gets down where it
kills you which is probably not good if
I just had to guess about the whole
death thing probably not good
[Music]
okay we're almost at the end of where
this allows me to go so let's peekaboo
in here [ __ ]
well now I'm infected by that thing but
I think there's a monitor in here it's
harmless over oh I wasn't now I am okay
well I got the creepy crawly on me now
that's good okay I hope that they didn't
change that to be lethal because that
would be fun okay just that yeah [ __ ]
that thing real hard I don't think
there's any way to actually contain this
ah ah I got an achievement I saw it okay
alright okay alright
I saw that okay I usually close my doors
by me I thought I closed them okay we
got the music total oh yeah that's the
music but I don't need to go in there
[Music]
okay wait a minute
we they had this in the unity version
did they always have it in this version
- I think I've done this I think I've
done this it is ringing a bell but I
know I'm not a hard person true
yeah no yeah it was okay so I'm not sure
if it's like I'm not gonna save just in
case cuz I know that it's like is the
longer you what the hook the longer you
watch the batter it gets for you yeah it
gets bad so I think it might be too late
I'm not sure oh boy yeah
I'm not gonna save I'm not gonna save I
think I've
yeah I've seen yeah I've seen that no
this wasn't in the unity version was it
no it wasn't was it maybe I don't know
but it ain't good oh yeah the story
behind this is pretty scary like this oh
yeah oh yeah they're aggressive oh yeah
I know yeah you see a lady die and then
I die
yep no this is death incoming so but I'm
just gonna show you guys just to remove
[ __ ] hey I can go in oh hell yeah I can
go it Hey
oh wow why are you doing that to my the
base of my neck ow
huh I seem to be blue I hope I seriously
I'm bleeding from Pam oh ow
listen Wow less lesson lesson lesson
listen listen
no need for that okay now we're back
here but that's okay la da de da da so
that was just a dead end I don't think
that there was anything of value to get
out of that I think I was just
let me check down here to see if there's
anything of value down here I don't
think there is but just in case let me
look what the [ __ ] they didn't roll no
no no no no no voiced most moist moist
door door door
get the dark Cathar okay Waluigi about
everything in here so I guess I hate
everything into whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
whoa okay wait no no don't
hey wait whoa boy wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa I don't know what's in here why are
we loading why'd we load don't load stop
loads don't load what is this
surveillance room what is that huh okay
hold on to your tits just for a second
what is surveillance running okay all
right let's just close this up
close that up okay all right
oh I remember this okay I remember the
surveillance room oh my mouse is getting
all [ __ ] again mom's getting all funky
I don't know why wait there's something
wait something's telling me bad stuff
comes tell me a big no-no on this some
I'm getting big no no things in my brain
I'm getting big no no big no toes in my
I'm getting big no nose in my head big
no nose in my er big no nose in my head
big no nose in my head
big no no then my head
hi I've got big nose in my head oh well
anyway you can talk about this we're
gonna talk about the hellooo
oh god he's smart he's learning hello
Doctor no no need for that doggy listen
doc listen listen you can just stay okay
never mind then I'll go this away ah
there's somebody behind me I'm gonna run
I'm a run running running quickly
Kathleen oh okay I don't know I didn't
get to unlock the containment zones
which is what I was supposed to do but I
was too much in a panic is he still
coming for me Oh for nine he's still on
the radar you think wait do you think
wait you think that it would do you
think it might oh he's somewhere wait
okay I'm gonna take this off and put on
the ring oh okay go back to where he was
got the ring on hey buddy listen hey
touch me
oh wait whoa whoa whoa hey listen okay
all right it works for a bit just
apparently not for long ah-ah-ah
okay I'm not sure if it just worked for
a bit but I think that I think that it
did I think that it did because it was
like Stata said stop resisting well
whereas ordinarily as soon as he touches
you your dunzo right yeah okay that was
cool okay we gotta go back up in there
and now this time when we go back up in
there I'm actually gonna turn oh yeah
I'm here okay
I'm actually gonna turn off the [ __ ] so
I'm not gonna go there cuz I don't need
to go there let's just go this way I
know that mr. Billy man's gonna be gonna
be over here for some reason I didn't
close this goddamn door oh yeah I was
looking for the loop-d-loop so I could
get the recursive dimension oh oh yeah
oh yeah that's right door appears to be
locked oh yes let's go this way
why'd you [ __ ] got the [ __ ] okay
okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
brute-force this bad boy I'm gonna keep
running here we go go Oh saw that Oh
yep okay that's that's different okay
big blood stain on the ground
I remember that okay going this for a
long time oh [ __ ] quick whoa whoa what's
that
[Music]
listen it fine
yeah it's fine I've never actually read
the wiki on this one but I actually
don't know what the true story is Oh yep
there's that body I was telling you
about
okay hey mister a hole in the head okay
all right you're right buddy
we're
okay my vision is doing something when I
look at that that's a little interesting
okay whatever carry on
[Music]
that's better okay whatever
all right well back to running that was
a bizarre turn of events but okay back
to me running I see that I see that the
unity Devils want to talk to me I see it
I'm pleasantly ignoring it because I'm
in the middle of something
can't you see I'm busy anything changed
no oh what ha ha what what
okay oh whoa whoa there he goes there is
there's there's our boy hey boy ah well
um a little bizarre but not too bizarre
okay all right well nothing new I think
I got to that point before but I think
someone told me after the fact that
after this there's even more and I
didn't get to that point so I just got
to keep going to the right oh you put
your right foot in do you put your right
foot out you put your right foot in and
then I'm sure you shake it all about
okay what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
quickly hang on I'm gonna quickly look
on the wick no okay so a document yeah
there it is
no my map no [ __ ] you my map my map my
map my map no not my map Oh my map for
this [ __ ] like white black white black
white grey I see that grey in there I'll
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh where's my
clipboard what'd you do with my
clipboard did you steal that god damn it
is that it is that it it says a random
item can appear oh you dick bag that was
it
duh [ __ ] you goddamnit
well that was it this note [ __ ] I
think I forgot that you [ __ ] dick bag
duh I got a reload my game is you I
gotta go I gotta go die too
I can't even look where I won through
this oh [ __ ] it [ __ ] [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
that and [ __ ] you I'm just gonna go die
get touched I'm gonna get to die I'm get
to stand I'm gonna die financal a buffet
of dicks yeah that's you wasting my time
wasting my time wasting my life you
being a douche you being a big dude ah
all right whatever jeez guy who's coming
up the stairs I want to wait for a
threat touch now we're going back into
it so that was a dick dick and dick
waste of my time dick dick dick dick
dick ursin
what do you corner camping piece of [ __ ]
are you kidding me you're gonna be by
the court oh oh hey how's it go
I can make this I can do this [ __ ] all
right where is it where is it
they're holding this whoa whoa corner of
my eye you say mmm watch this maneuvers
I can totally beat the snot out of any
stupid SCP that thinks days smarter than
May and days ain't days ain't that's for
damn sure
all right the way I needed to do this
because I needed to lift the lockdown on
this area so lift lockdown and then you
I bet you can actually see him walking
in right that's all deal right
oh you had areas hey Bob Dave hey buddy
buddy hey or imma save real quick
nope can't save okay that's probably for
the best though hey buddy
hey buddy how about I hide you can't see
me right there's no way that you could
all [ __ ] it saves me all right I'm out
of here you get you get you get have fun
you get have fun you have fun with you
[ __ ] you get oh god okay well I don't
need to run so he's pretty slow if this
is true then this should open for me
right I did I did okay I did oh [ __ ]
what a code what do you mean a code just
when did I need a code oh [ __ ] they're
like one oh is it like a code on any of
these ah yeah I guess I could get
touched by Larry and try to go through
that way but I really don't want to
ah good [ __ ] that's good [ __ ] that's
good [ __ ] right there that's that's good
[ __ ] that's good [ __ ] funny funny okay
so [ __ ] okay so there's another oh wait
maybe that's just cuz that one is maybe
just cuz that one's not well uh no no
not gonna ear me like let me throw not
gonna hear me again so I gotta go back
the other way which means I'm gonna run
into the doctor again but I can get
around that that was too close but I
haven't saved so that's that's another
conundrum while I'm running from him
okay there you can't I'll try to get him
I'm gonna get around them in this area
I'm gonna put on the ring and the mask I
think both of those should allow me to
run enough
no no it doesn't okay
[ __ ] okay well at least I have just I
have the ring so if I get around him
like there we go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] come on
faster please
plaster would be great faster would be
great lil faster okay I'm a dick okay Oh
why if it isn't just [ __ ] mark in the
butthole day all right fine I'm gonna go
save I'm gonna go save and there's
nothing that you can do about it and
then the oh [ __ ] mr. Larry man come at
me [ __ ] boy
oh [ __ ] why that's not right wait no
where the [ __ ]
Oh mister [ __ ] ditch come back over
here mom save just gonna save it's all I
want to do save saving
all right we're good
everything's fine we're all kinds of
good yeah we're spicy oh [ __ ] are we
gonna do come on come on me come on you
think that's it huh come at me come come
even closer come closer
Oh cousin let's go bowling come closer
come closer
there you go [ __ ] dicks alright tits
alright we got that to go sweet deals
where's the nearest saved from here okay
where am i exactly in terms of the map
okay so I think behind me is another
gonna be a dead end as far as it goes I
think the only true one is the one on
the right over there that's right
because some of them aren't right well
they have access codes and that's not
right but I think I think I can get to
the right one and then I can cross over
there that's that's definitely a thing
this one says it's got one more where
does that go then
okay yeah but this one sure to just go
dude oh [ __ ] yeah almost I almost had
you okay so I got to come back here I
have to come back here for the computer
man he's just in a little area of his
own I didn't know that that's kind of
inconvenient what are the Admiral thing
about some admirable things about this
game is that it's it's completely like
randomly generated oh boy okay I could
go down I don't like going down down is
like the last place I like to go but you
know [ __ ] it [ __ ] it here we go
now I should have at least just saved
goddamnit yeah I don't know if which
switch which basement is it gonna be oh
I want to go back up and I want to say
I'm gonna go through this
now we can do the Nazi thing add a
little touch to the skull oh we can't
carry anymore well I'll just drop this
cup of that cup of skull
may I have cup of skull please yeah this
is like a holocaust thing hi
okay yeesh
well there was more to that I swear
there was more weird I thought there was
more I thought there was more okay I
guess that's it then
carrying on at least I got a save oh
that's right oh maybe oh maybe not just
that's right that's so cool I don't even
remember that was whoo
[Music]
I know
Oh your face seems to be melting sir I
don't want that achievement can you take
that achievement back that's [ __ ] up
man
that's [ __ ] up it's a good it's a good
book
horrible subject matter but well
everything about that horrible
here we go
I don't hear him
but
Miles's changed huh Bow Wow
what no thank you no thank you no thank
you no thank you
wait was that just was that actually
them coming for me was that just a
random well [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's bad
that's bad
okay well I'm [ __ ] oh I'm so [ __ ] I
don't know if I can get away from
Oh Sena that ahem Oh
Oh
hmm
yeah I definitely need the hand for some
kind of handprint scanner
I know there's two of them I know
there's two of them
so the way these guys work for those who
don't know there are two very obviously
horrible monsters but what they do is
they mimic the last thing that they
heard so the way they're going like oh
god
the way they're going like Oh God and no
it's because those are the last things
that the people they ate said before
they died and show yourself
where where where who the hell is that I
don't hear where are you who the hell is
that who's that
I hate it I hate it so much they've
improved this too
I can't tell where that's coming from
oh no I keep getting fooled by that
don't [ __ ]
give me I don't know what to do here
it's just somebody else
I thought I lost you for a moment there
[ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate that okay so that lever
opened up something I don't know what
maybe one of these big swinging maybe
one of these big doors I don't know
where that opened it I know it's so dark
that you can barely see anything but
it's like I got nothing else to do for
it it's super dark just go please
okay
I think
Oh show yourself what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] where is that one I think if I
follow this one down it's down this way
but I'm not a hundred percent sure about
that
there Oh what is that oh oh oh that's
night-vision um I don't know if I'm
gonna need [ __ ] the battery I don't need
the battery no battery you not now not
now give me the [ __ ] thing
Oh God Oh I didn't need the battery for
this [ __ ] okay
well at least I can see him now let me
let me think about
I'm just gonna what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna drop this for a second I'm gonna
pick up the battery and I'm just pop
this in no it's full okay it's full
about this okay we're going okay this is
a little something one
why are you [ __ ] me I'm just gonna
go to the elevator again imma get the
[ __ ] out of here on the [ __ ] e out I am
the [ __ ] yeah I am so lucky
maybe there wait is there like No
okay we still have a chance to get out
of this we just have to
we just gotta find the way out let's get
the Bernie note this will help I guess
maybe here's the burnt note okay drop
this for a second foot dish in here drop
whatever dist no come on drop this over
here I guess drop the burnt note here
grab the bat I don't think we need this
badge in any way shape okay so let's see
if we can see something down these
hallways at least there anything that
looks like it might be some kind of good
no they'll look just about the same to
me yeah they all woof [ __ ] you
they all look every kind of the same
this is pick one and go die cuz that's
what we got okay
okay give me that hand baby give me that
sweet hand oh that's a nice hand okay
I'm gonna get rid of this cuz Emily Ross
as much as I care I don't think I can
pass for Emily Ross oh can i oh really
oh that's so nice oh that's so nice oh
oh that's
I'm not okay thanks for asking
definitely not okay
I don't know how I literally sprinted in
this area without running straight
straight into ins I don't know how I did
that but somehow I avoided death okay
section three you know I got section
three who's that what the [ __ ] who's is
there someone through that door know
that that must be it there's someone
through that door so there's no there's
more than down here oh [ __ ] and I was
killing time being here okay but I think
it's okay okay I don't know I don't know
if there's like another section that I
need to be about if there's another
switch that I need to flip but I got a
hand I think there are three there
apparently are I only remember two but
apparently there's three and there's one
behind a big door so I whoa oh all right
then
that's that's not good Oh
okay I'm just gonna get out here I'm
gonna get out here I'm gonna get out
here because [ __ ] this noise [ __ ] this
noise I'm Audi
I'm dunzo before I'm gonna save I don't
know what I don't know what the hell
that is all about I don't know what's
going on there I don't remember I don't
know
they've changed it and I'm not about
changes I saw that other corner of my
eye who do we got near me
lots of people okay that's not good
we're okay let's get in here
let's give us a view baby okay or I call
that there so that was a beacon to a
marriage it's it's really fascinating
how after so many episodes of this it
can still leave me my heart pumping like
crazy and not knowing what to do with
myself it is nuts but I love it so I'm
gonna keep doing this but unfortunately
I have to go so thank you everybody so
much for watching I will get to SCP
unity the next time I have time I have
other stuff that I'm doing if I have
time I'm gonna keep making more videos
later tonight but for now thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next
[Music]